So one way we could do this operation is to allocate the maximum space per element.
In this case we would create an output array with 5 output triangles per input triangle.
And we're going to put these in an intermediate array and then compact the result.
However, this has 2 significant disadvantages.
The first is that it's really wasteful in space.
We've now allocated an intermediate array that has the maximum amount of space per element,
and that's going to lead to a very large array overall.
The second disadvantage is that now we have to scan this large intermediate array,
and that's not going to be as efficient as we would like either.
So how can we do this more efficiently?
So let's go back to what we'd really like to do.
What we'd like to do is have a list of allocation requests, 1 per input element,
and then get back a location to write your requests.
As an example, let's say we have 8 input triangles here, and those 8 triangles want to generate,
in order, 1, 0, 1, 2, 1, 0, 3, and 0 triangles.
So what's that going to look like?
The first input element is going to want to write its 1 triangle here into the output array.
The second triangle isn't going to have any output elements to write.
The third input triangle is wanting to write into this element here. The next triangle has 2 outputs.
It will write them into the next 2 slots of the array.
The next triangle wants to write its output here. The next triangle wants to write nothing.
The next triangle wants to write its output into these 3 output slots.
So what we want to generate here is the output addresses for these.
He wants to write his output into address 0. He wants to write his output into address 1.
He wants to write his output into address 2 and 3.
And this guy wants to write his output into addresses 5, 6, and 7, and so on.
And look. This is exclusive scan as well.
It generalizes what we did with compact.
In compact we allocated 1 slot in the output array for each true element and 0 for each false element.
Instead, now we've generalized this so that we simply indicate in the input array
the exact number that we need.
This is simpler and it's more efficient.
Instead of scanning an array that has the maximum possible allocation for all elements--
in the case of clipping, 5 times the size of the input array--
now we just have to scan something the size of the input array.
So it's more efficient to be able to do it this way.
So that's a couple of interesting applications of scan.
If you're doing any sort of GPU programming with irregular workloads,
you'll find that scan comes up all the time.
Recent work has used scan in diverse application domains, such as graft reversal,
data compression, and collision detection, among many others.
And we'll see later in this lecture that scan is the core of the fastest GPU sort as well.